hello and welcome to this video playing
the Blitz master with the double zet
julep up okay because there's also a
blitz master i believe with get the
correct spelling check and is not from
hungary okay see for them interesting
move mmm more what is probably just 96
how bad can it be yeah going for the
roxy bite now the bishop autism I'm
interesting to see how is he going to
play that now just with Bishop e3 okay
well one thing I definitely don't mind
if I get into amarok see here on the
black side is to being able to trade
some pieces that is almost invariably
tube legs and vantage I mean not like
black it's better not that but it's
normally an accomplishment to get
something straight it so I'm going to
force that him I think it will also
trade the bishops if he retreats the
Bishop to e3 let's say after this I will
just take c3 and black is better i guess
this is this pawn structure should be
excellent for me so he will trade on
allow me to trade one of the two i would
also be happy to take on d4 and play
Queen B 6 the more you trade with black
and lets structure the better your
equalizing chances get some I'm happy
with that I think I'm actually a king
ugh one looks like a good move so that
after takes Queen B 6 you can go back to
the two and don't trade queens so I
figure that is what you automatically
will play maybe 95 or
tively so I'm I was right about that but
okay still he cannot avoid the trade and
might as well just play rook c8 he moves
the bishop away he's still not
threatening to move it away so i have
time him can't even go here maybe to
activate the Queen a little bit 95 is
possible but I have rupee eight and yeah
it's okay
given the choice that still rather be
white but with the traits um I can be
reasonably reasonably happy I think
Queen c5 is coming next Quincy five if
you move the Queen away and I will
probably go Knight b6 trying to trade
the night now well not be six is not the
greatest move the heck they I have some
process running in the background some
some blunder checking and form for
analysis okay so crew to d2 cell a4
surprising I'm happy about that so what
do we have here might be sick siebel go
back but Knight f6 is interesting now
and because the trade is no problem at
all as the e power now is weak it just
as we go even a week upon than the d6
pawn so i assume is going back to see
three now and then now i can go back to
see three that's also just a decent move
to be perfectly honest okay I'm not sure
that I light Knight f6 now that's III is
good yeah taking is not not great but
this one yeah this is also possible of
course hmm
Oh ticking and then e6 that leaves
weaknesses behind not very happy with
that but it is tough to avoid let's do
it it's tough to avoid and
it feels like I should be able to get in
d5 for a decent decent enough position
let's see d5 immediately if he takes
with the rukon is 6 i'll takes you far
this should be ok so let's push this
immediately it takes with the pawn Queen
takes I think is also fine I'm attacking
b3 and ma'am that that should be ok it's
very difficult to get out of this maroc
see bind structure to get anything
active going with black hello I know it
looks a little bit dull that I'm mostly
trying to trade down here but it's a
there is some there is there isn't a
there's no great great option for
anything better I don't quite understand
i can take yard where's he going what is
it going for takes on eighth five maybe
i can take it for though yeah that is
hanging hmm tough tough to cover her
rupee aids not exactly helpful but ok
don't think I can play for an advantage
in this position i bought the odds a
week yeah I can perpetual among or have
one now and probably a short-term or
here this is probably better check check
is there any alternative hear me never
tickets always a check this is the thing
I can take a form but then it takes
eight and b7 that's also not helping at
all and I can move the rook now that is
a third as an idea maybe but we're time
money and to put it rook c8 is going
just back just to the back rank it's
also probably not helping huh but check
here no it's a draw not much you cannot
do anything anything serious and wrong
at least I didn't see it um just the
engine find anything no there's nothing
I was thinking um yeah like rook c8 here
for example but you can't do that for
Queenie six come on bloody software okay
I have to kill that process typical
chest based product just just not any
good okay so let's go back
the basic functions of chat space is ok
that they have some really crappy parts
of software ok so it's a bit unusual how
he played at him let's see for a move
usually white is taking on chat d7 and
only now go see for on former oxy by but
it's am it went like that the thing is
what I can do maybe which is a little
bit more ambitious maybe to play a 60
and try to yell at white caps on c6 I
mean this is what I played is just solid
very solid and probably leading to
complete equality or they are close to
that Yemen white probably still has a
slide slide pull down but it's not it's
not much going back a five now to get
the c5 square now I went for 96 yeah
which leads to all those trades I've
also thought about this briefly but I
wasn't sure about it that can be a
really read porn I have some ideas
myself but I was I wasn't sure so I just
went went with this trade it yeah this
is like not really helping because I get
this counter play here if he covers the
the pawn I'm just very very solid here
can do this maybe 55 and then I go rupee
five you know it's it's just equal this
is better what he did this this and now
he thinks it's it's tough to get yeah
it's tough to avoid yeah I'm not so
happy about it but it's tough to avoid
Luke takes NTM I should be I shouldn't
be a fine d5 does equalize completely i
guess was a bit surprised by a
three-word
doesn't really mean it doesn't really
hurt why its chances queen bee six is a
good move u6 and b7 saying was check I
think it was a very correct game very
correct but same time not very exciting
i have to admit but sometimes you just
have to play a good move such you can do
in little time so sometimes gets to be
somewhat unspectacular okay well thanks
for watching